my MVP conversation five right now for
me I'm about to go with Lamar Jackson
number four I'm going go with Tua
actually I'm not even going number four
with Tua I have to go with Tyreek number
three for me will be Brock pie number
two Jaylen Herz and number one will be
Dak Prescott and I did this because I
know it's a QB based award so that's why
Tyreek didn't make my top three but
Tyreek is easily in a top three if not
number one if he breaks his record he
has to be MVP he's taking screens for 60
and 70 yards he is is going absolutely
berserk Dak he is the best quarterback
in NFL right now it's a QB R award he
will be MVP most likely and Tyreek will
end up being offensive player of the
year